[Music]
welcome to architecting with google
cloud i'm max saltinstall and lately
i've been thinking security is a
constant challenge in the cloud and
never fully solved
most companies work with a variety of
vendors and platforms and solutions to
keep their people as safe as possible
today i'm pleased to welcome mason from
palo alto networks to talk a little bit
about how their solutions work well with
google's security products
hi mason welcome can you tell me a
little bit about who you are what your
role is and what you're doing right now
thank you max
my name is mason ian i'm with platon
network for about three years
i lead the google cloud alliance
technical team my team has been building
better together solution with google
cloud
we help customers
use
plato networks and google cloud together
that's awesome and palo alto networks
and google both have a lot of different
security products so
palo alto networks can help in many ways
and can integrate with google right yeah
that's correct
so
you know we promote a cyber security
platform approach
we cover across the cloud security
network security sassy
access you know secure access service
ads which is allow all users
access from anywhere security
we also cover endpoint security
and security operations
the benefit of the platform approach
is to allow customers use consistent
security policies
eliminate gaps
of course you know the skill issue has
been you know challenging in the
security industry
you can never
hire enough security professionals right
we try to do
automation as much as possible
we try to help customers solve 95 of
their alerts automatically the customer
can really focus on the five percent
that's awesome because it sounds like
it's gonna save me time and energy and
give me better security
and if i recall this partnership between
google and palo alto networks has been
pretty darn successful right yeah that's
correct we are very proud that plato
networks
was awarded as the technology partner of
the year for the past three consecutive
years out of thousands google cloud
technology partners sounds great and we
all love it when everything works
perfectly but what happens when
something actually goes wrong and how
are you able to help me with some of
these solutions yeah as you know no
matter how good your security solution
is the bridge is happening
when it happens
you want to minimize the damage right so
you risk against the time
that's the life at security operations
you know the tools like cortex xcr
stop the breaches
because it does you know it's not only
have the visibility to your endpoint but
also to your firewall in the network and
your cloud assets and security events in
your cloud so getting that visibility
helps me respond and helps me
minimize the blast radius can
this help me against both small hobbyist
attackers and big professional hackers
yeah that's the goal right so you must
heard of apt
advanced persistent threshold
the most sophisticated separate
criminals right
so they are equipped with advanced
attack software techniques and create
you know the creating a tremendous
challenge to security professionals
so how would we know our cybersecurity
solutions is robust enough can protect
us from apt's attack
so industry uses meteor attack
evaluations
you know the evaluation
you know it's really
test the user test the solutions like
you know if the solution could detect
and protect from apt's attacks
so the evaluation emulates the
real-world attack sequences apt uses
right and cortax xdr was run the highest
protection and the visibility combined
score out of 29 solutions last year
cortex scr blocked 100 of the tag in the
protection phase against the both the
linux and windows endpoint wow that's
fantastic so let's say i'm at a company
and we want to operate in a zero trust
way but i also need to understand what's
the current state of all these different
computers that my people have especially
when many of them are bringing their own
devices they're working from home and i
can't necessarily reach out and touch
and check and update those so can you
help me with that yeah so you know for
the zero trust google has been building
a very stiff access control uh to the
cloud resources and the sas applications
right so which is part of the vmware
architecture
contacts aware access level provided a
cloud-native way to control the access
i think one of the biggest challenge as
you mentioned is to understand the
security postures of your endpoints
right and you don't want a compromised
endpoint to access your cloud resources
and sas applications
cortex xvr deploys the security agents
to the endpoints
the agent stop mower exploit and run
somewhere
cortex-scr created alerts incidents from
malicious activities at input
think about if we can just add this
endpoint security posture as part of the
google beyond course contacts policy you
know contacts aware policy right so i
think we can prevent a compromised
computer from accessing cloud resources
and sas applications that sounds great
so by putting some software on my
employees machines you're both helping
me stop those attacks on the one hand
and detecting malicious activity to flag
a machine as compromised so what's all
the magic behind the scenes that's
giving you the information to calculate
a health level for each device
yeah so the cortex scr
they include a bra
you know the set of the exploit uh
protection module right so it could
protect you from you know the mower
infection you know exploits um and also
uh the cortex xdr could actually protect
you from a malicious file download right
so you know
we pretty much have a two phases
the first we would just examine the file
locally and use the machine learning
building and to figure out if this file
is first thing if there's a no file and
if the local analysis is not able to
figure out we have a
industry well-known uh security service
sandbox service called wildfire right
the file will get uploaded welfare
welfare should be able to figure out if
we detect some new zero data you know
malware and we would notify the entire
palado's in surveys right so everybody
got a benefit from this analysis
that's great and that sounds like it's
going to keep
lots of my computers much much safer so
this output also plugs into google's
security system so that i can make good
decisions about
how healthy or how safe one individual
client device is right and then that
lets me decide whether to let it in or
not yeah that's correct so
for that purpose we joined google the
encore alliance program we developed a
solution called cortex xdr endpoint
verification
so the first release
we pretty much measure three things
right so number one we want to make sure
the endpoint is protected by cortex-scr
agent and number two the endpoint should
not be isolated by your security admin
right so that means the endpoint is
compromised right so number three we
want to make sure there is a
uh you know house score um you know the
house score is meet your threshold you
set up
so you know the we calculate the
threshold in the first release by alerts
number of learners you know if the
analysis severed enough
and the next release we're gonna also
include the instance information and
those alerts and future incidents those
are based on
fishy activity basically right yep
that's correct okay so this is going to
make me a lot more secure
how is it going to help me prevent
some compromise or intrusion yeah so our
uh you know solution we automatically
update google's endpoint management with
the endpoint security posture from
cortex xdr
you know once we have that done uh you
know you can create a context-aware
access policy right
you know then you can use google for
example iap vpc service control to
control access to
the cloud resources and also the same
access level you can apply you know the
access policy to your sas application
you know including the workspace and
third-party applications
so
get this agent on all my devices
set up some kind of endpoint
data store hook it all up to google's
zero trust posture this sounds like a
lot of work do i have to do all of that
manually by myself you know we try to
make this deployment as easy as possible
right so you know i think
what you would need to do uh is just
deploy the cloud function we build and
you know to your cloud environment and
the cloud function would just uh reach
out to cortex xdr um you know the api
and the cortex sdr will reach out to
endpoint get endpoint security posture
information uh you know the solution
review would automatically update uh the
google
endpoint management and from there you
know the access level you can fix will
take the magic you can prevent that
compromise endpoint access the cloud
resources and also
the sas application great so
in the unlikely but inevitable event
that something bad does happen
how is this going to also help me
minimize the damage restrict the blast
radius yeah so if anything has happened
right so the first step that cortax dr
agent
would prevent you know the mower you
know run somewhere exploit uh to damage
your endpoint but at the same time the
cortex icr agent would create alert
create incidents and those security
password information
would get transferred into google
endpoint management and the google's
contacts aware access level will prevent
a compromised endpoint from accessing
google resource and also the sas
application awesome so let's say i want
to try this out and move forward what
should i do first
so cortex scr endpoint verification is
in private preview at this point contact
us at google at platonnetworks.com
we will get you started that's awesome
thank you very much mason for joining
and for telling us about some of these
really cool innovative security
solutions
thank you max my pleasure to talk to you
really appreciate you
uh promote the cortex xdr endpoint
verification uh for beyondcorp thank you
if you liked what you saw today and you
want to see more like it you can check
out the full playlist below please make
sure you like and subscribe to get more
content from architecting with google
cloud
[Music]
you